Here's our data, and you'll see that the sample size is 25. It says 26 here
because we have a header. So let's find the average of the QWERTY errors,
equals average A2 to A26, and we get 5.08. And then if we find the average of
the errors made on that alphabetical keyboard, we get 7.8. We want to see if
there's a significant difference between the number of errors made on each
keyboard. Our null hypothesis is that there is no significant difference. The
population of errors from this keyboard, if it were extended to everybody, not
just the sample, equals the population of errors using this keyboard. And our
alternative hypothesis, is that they're not equal. Notice that this is
equivalent to saying that mu sub Q minus mu sub A equals 0. If we just subtract
mu sub A on both sides of this equation, which basically says that the
difference is equivalent to about 0.